paroles et à notre collègue bruno roux
juin pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre chargé des comptes
publics en pleine préparation de leurs
budgets 2022 un grand nombre de
collectivités territoriales tire le
signal d'alarmé avec près de 35 %
d'augmentation du prix de l'électricité
les répercussions sur les finances
locales sont importantes on assiste à
une hausse brutale
sauf pour les contrats à prix fixes et à
la difficulté de passer un nouveau
marché à des prix raisonnables pour les
fins de contrat
l'association des maires de france et la
fnccr estime que cette augmentation
s'échelonnent de 30% à 300% neuf
communes sur dix seraient impactés
l'ademe évalué à 4 milliards d'euros
leurs dépenses en énergie en 2017 le
surcoût cette fois dépassent 1 milliard
l'addition est salée la crise coheed a
nécessité beaucoup d'efforts pour
suppléer l'état les collectivités vont
être contraintes de renoncer à certains
investissements
il est vrai que certaines sont en partie
préservée grâce à des contrats aux
tarifs réglementés de vente mais la
plupart n'y sont plus éligibles monsieur
le ministre faisons en sorte que tout
puisse de nouveau accéder à ce tarif
réglementé j'ai entendu le gouvernement
s'inquiétait du sort des ménages et des
entreprises confrontée à ces difficultés
n'oubliez pas que tous les échelons
locaux sont également fortement impactés
si la hausse de l'inflation va entraîner
une revalorisation des bases locatives
l'augmentation des recettes fiscales
sera loin de compenser celle du prix de
l'énergie monsieur le ministre quel
message aujourd'hui adressez vous aux
collectivités territoriales qui
s'inquiète une fois de plus de la
réduction de leur capacité financière
bon monsieur olivier dussopt a pris dix
délégués recherche des comptes publics
pour vous répondre merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur quelques
éléments pour apporter des réponses à
votre interrogation sur un sujet qui
concerne les collectivités qui concerne
aussi l'état on interrogeait communistes
des comptes publics comme les écoles
publiques avec ma collègue en charge de
la transition écologique nous avons eu
cours de l'automne dernier à réviser un
certain nombre de contrats du fait des
difficultés rencontrées par nos propres
fournisseurs et nous avons aussi pour
l'état dû faire face à une augmentation
des tarifs qui représente un coût qui
n'est pas négligeable cela nous amène
avec le premier ministre à faire preuve
d'une grande attention au sujet du coût
de l'énergie pour l'ensemble des acteurs
privés comme publics il ya aujourd'hui
deux types d'éléments que je veux porter
à votre attention et qu'ils peuvent être
rassurant à ce stade en tout cas premier
élément tient au fait que nous avons
pris un certain nombre de dispositions
qui s'appliquent aux collectivités
locales les collectivités locales
bénéficient comme les particuliers de la
baisse de la tennis et feu elle en
bénéficie notamment lorsqu'elles sont
alimentés pour des activités qui n'ont
pas de nature commerciale qui ne sont
pas assujettis à la tva et elles sont
traitées comme des entreprises par
contre pour les activités qui relèvent
d'un assujettissement à la tva la
deuxième chose que je souhaite souligner
tient en fait que les décisions que nous
avons prises avec bruno le maire
consistant à relever le volume de
production au titre de la reine
bénéficier aussi aux collectivités et là
où des hausses de 40 % auraient pu être
constaté la hausse du volume de la reine
ramène crs à 20% enfin vous l'avez dit
les collectivités de plus petite taille
celle quand une section de
fonctionnement avec un budget de moins
de 2 millions d'euros ou moins de dix 10
équivalent temps-plein bénéficient du
tarif réglementé et par le tarif
réglementé voit l'augmentation du prix
de l'électricité limitée à 4% ainsi que
le prix du gaz limitée au montant du
mois d'octobre vous vous inquiétez de la
capacité des collectivités à faire face
je l'indiqué tout à l'heure au sénateur
mark les compensations sous forme de tva
vont se traduire pour l'ensemble des
collectivités par une augmentation de 2
milliards d'euros par rapport à 2021 par
ailleurs la dynamique des recettes
fiscales est certaine il ya une
dynamique lié à une évolution des bases
elle tient au développement des
collectivités il ya une révision
forfaitaire des valeurs locatives à
hauteur de 3 4% cela représente de
manière cumulée entre quatre et cinq
fois le montant craint et non encore
constatée du prix de l'énergie pour les
collectivités cela reste rassurant à ce
stade vous que j'envoie le gouvernement
de faire preuve de la plus grande
vigilance
merci
monsieur roja ou si vous le souhaitez
quelques secondes monsieur le ministre
protéger les finances des collectivités
locales n'oubliez jamais que 70% de
l'investissement est réalisé en france
l'investissement public par elle et que
le milliard ces 2 % d'investissements en
moins et l'impact sur l'emploi et
l'économie générale merci merci
[Applaudissements]
d'abord